[Music]
good morning everyone Christmas is
coming but there's been no Miracle to
avert strikes on the railways the rmt
has rejected a payoffer and announced
more stoppages an escalation that the
transport secretary described as
incredibly disappointing
rail strikes will take place as planned
on the 13th and 14th of December and
then on the 16th and 17th of December
new strikes have been announced for the
Christmas holidays they'll start at 6
p.m on Christmas Eve and run until the
morning of the 27th of December more
strikes are also planned for the start
of the new year on the third and fourth
of January and on the 6th and 7th of
January
oh my goodness Dan standing by for is in
Bristol this is just not what people
wanted to hear is it Dan good morning
Kay it really isn't it is going to be a
month of strikes in December really
starting that winter of discontent as
you say this latest strike action being
announced by at the rmt will start at 6
p.m on Christmas Eve that big Christmas
getaway which sees stations like Bristol
Temple meets incredibly busy people
heading from London to this big Junction
where they change to go North to go
Wales to go to the South West are going
to face severe disruption 6 p.m it
starts as you say on Christmas Eve right
through till 6 a.m on the 27th now
usually of course there aren't many
trains that run on Christmas Day and
boxing day but it will be the disruption
caused by the network rail workers going
on strike which will have a massive
knock-on effect either side of those
dates in the run-up to Christmas and it
comes on top of those strike dates which
already start next week 13th and 14th
the 16th and 17th and into dates in
January this of course is all over this
long-running dispute between the unions
and rail bosses and network rail overpay
over jobs over reforms and conditions
now this latest offer they're actually
two negotiations going on with rmt one
with the real delivery group one with
network rail this latest offer from
Network rail is being put actually in an
electronic referendum to its members
that closes on Monday but the
recommendation from Mick Lynch the rmt
general secretary is for its members to
reject them the payoff is on the table
at the minute are around four to five
percent in terms of a pay increase what
they're really concerned about the
unions is the conditions and and the
changes things like drivers operating
doors and the closure of ticket offices
as I say a winter of this discontent
because it's not just Railway workers
who are striking in the passengers who
are going to face disruption we're
looking at Royal Mail nurses
firefighters teachers bus drivers all
planning strike action over the festive
period And as I say not just the
passengers here and across the country
who are going to face disruption
businesses as well are going to be
impacted UK hospital yesterday warning
that the impact for them in December is
going to be Circa 1.5 billion pounds
okay thank you
we'll be speaking to a government
Minister about that lots of other things
as well about quarter past seven here on
the program so do stay tuned for more on
that meantime questions are being raised
about images used in Harry and Megan's
explosive Netflix trailer criticism has
focused on a picture which shows a group
of photographers supposedly fighting for
a snap of the royal couple but which was
in fact from a Harry Potter Premiere in
2011.
no Royals attended and it's now claimed
that at least four Images used to
promote the series are not what they
seem let's get more with Martha
[Music]
no one knows the full truth
we know the full truth the question now
is whether Harry and Megan's truth laid
out in this new documentary tallies with
the recollection of others and public
record there's a hierarchy of the family
you know there's leaking but there's
also planting of Stories the claytons
are certainly explosive and damning for
the Royals family but what about the
legitimacy of the pictures used to
illustrate them this image used in the
trailer to show an apparent Feeding
Frenzy around Megan it was taken at a
Harry Potter Premiere five years before
the couple met and a picture of them
seemingly being stalked by a
photographer in fact an authorized press
call
Netflix has paid Harry and Megan around
90 million pounds for a number of
collaborative projects but there's no
doubt about it the true value for the
streaming giant lies behind this
documentary series they want to heighten
anticipation ahead of its release and
they've been very successful in doing so
it's a dirty game
pain and suffering of women marrying
into this institution this feeling
Frenzy
any illusion of a truth brought about by
the Queen's death shattered in a
50-second advert a move which is likely
to pit Harry and Megan directly Against
The Prince and Princess of Wales
in America now home to the couple and to
the bulk of the Netflix audience opinion
is divided
Harry and Megan have their supporters
and they have their detractors in the US
just as they do in the UK and those
people who are
coin a popular phrase ride or die for
Megan and Harry really are just that
they are team Sussex Sussex Squad and
they will go to the mattresses for Harry
and Megan I have to do everything I
could to protect my family the timing of
the series release on Thursday exactly
three months after the Queen's death a
stinging the tail for the royal family
another crisis for the new king this
time Unleashed by his son and
daughter-in-law Martha kalner Sky News
Los Angeles
is outside Buckingham Palace for us this
morning first episode released on
Thursday I believe Ashner a question
that a lot of people are asking is given
what we saw with previous interviews
what more is there to tell
I think it's absolutely going to be
incredibly explosive I think there are
going to be some quite damaging
allegations and I think many people
waking up inside the palace behind me
today will be feeling a little
uncomfortable perhaps some of them
absolutely Furious on one hand you've
got people that say perhaps this is the
right time Harry and Megan have to have
their say once again of course they did
do that explosive Oprah interview about
a year and a half ago but other people
will argue well they're not being
fact-checked they're not being
challenged by in any of this documentary
this is in their own words and that's
already been highlighted in some of the
promotional material that's been
released in two of the trailers we have
seen images multiple images of the press
and we know that perhaps the blame with
the UK press is going to be even more
reinforced in this documentary
particularly by Harry himself but
there's some questions over the use of
particularly images that show
um press with long lens cameras some of
them are some of the images shown were
taken from other events and in fact
where the couple weren't even present in
one one of those images it was taken
whilst filming the reality TV star Katie
Price in another they were filming uh
Donald Trump's former lawyer Michael
Cohen and in another it was taken at the
very last Harry Potter Premiere here in
London in which as you say Okay none of
the Royals were present so some
questions over exactly what material
we're going to get all whilst we're
seeing that material they're talking
about being hounded by the UK press and
alleging that those photographs are from
events that perhaps they were at not
only is the blame being appointed at the
Press but also potentially at the family
too and at the institution and that's
where the worry is going to come of
course the palace though have to be
quite strategic in their response we're
going to get the first part as you say
of this docu-series on Thursday they'll
have to be quite strategic and what they
say on that day because they know that
further down the line come next week
there's going to be even more
allegations on the table uh let's move
on to Ukraine Russia's defense Ministry
has said that a Ukrainian drone attack
caused explosions at two military air
bases deep inside Russia Ukraine has not
claimed responsibility let's get more
should we Diana standing by for us in
Moscow good morning Diana the latest
from where you are please
hi Kay yes will Ukraine never claims
responsibility for these kinds of tax on
Russian territory for example on Crimea
which obviously isn't Russian territory
but which Russia claims it is but as you
say this is the furthest that
um targets have been hit within Russia
since the start of this war two military
air bases targeted one 115 kilometers or
miles south west of Moscow liaison so
pretty close to Moscow another around
400 miles from the border with Ukraine
in southern Russia so a long way away
from Ukraine's borders and both of those
bases housed strategic military bombers
that Russia has been using to Target
um Ukraine's energy infrastructure and
Military infrastructure in Russia in
Ukraine sorry over the course of the
last 10 months so there are a lot of
questions now about how exactly Ukraine
managed it do they have a drone capable
of traveling that kind of a distance was
this a missile was there some kind of
counterintelligence failure within
Russia that allowed a drone from within
Russia perhaps with the help of
Ukrainian collaborators to Target these
bases a lot of questions being asked now
in the military blogosphere about how
exactly this was allowed to happen
Russia's response was as you might
expect expect again to send another
round of missiles into Ukraine
um all of this started of course those
missile strikes in Ukraine because of
the attack on the Kirch Bridge linking
Crimea with Russia and we saw pictures
from President Putin yesterday actually
driving across that bridge to symbolize
the fact that it's now been reopened to
passenger transport interesting pictures
if you have to show if you have them to
show we do thank you very much indeed
Diana for the update yeah those are the
images that Diana was just talking about
there uh back here in the studio let's
bring in the school Minister Nick Gibb
should we hello Mr Gibb it's good to see
you this morning lots to talk about I
wondered if I could start with an eighth
child or having died from strep a
suggestions from one of your health
ministers Lord Markham that if there's a
an outbreak of strep a in a class then
all those kids should get antibiotics is
that something that you're going to do
well this is a tragic for the parents of
those eight children who've lost their
child due to this bacteria and what the
UK health and Security Agency are doing
is they're working closely with the
schools involved and giving very
specific advice to those schools which
may involve use of penicillin and so on
and they'll have more to say about that
and they're providing more general
advice to parents which is to look out
for the symptoms so a sore throat fever
high temperature and also a red or
raised rash on the skin are symptoms of
this invasive uh Strep A outbreak
um one of the things that is your
responsibility as a government is to
keep these kids warm at school
apparently the bills for energy have
gone up 300 what are you doing about it
well a number of things the energy
relief scheme of course is helping
schools over this coming winter and
today we've also announcing 500 million
pounds of capital for schools so a
typical Primary School will get sixteen
thousand pounds of a typical Secondary
School 42 000 pounds to enable them very
rapidly to put in place energy saving
measures like LED lighting or better
lagging of pipes and better thermostat
control to help them bring down their
their energy costs and of course all
this follows a major two billion pound
extra funding for schools in the Autumn
statement both next year and the year
after in addition to the money that had
already been allocated to school which
is a very good settlement for schools to
help them deal with with these kinds of
pressures all four major teaching units
are balancing their members about
possible strike action is this
government losing control
no not not at all look I understand the
the pressure that teachers and teaching
assistants feel that they are and they
were all under pressure because of the
cost of living and we're trying to
tackle that and that's what the awesome
statement did it brought in a range of
measures uh to help with the cost of
living teachers uh our pay is determined
by an independent pay review body and
and this year for this September they
were awarded a five percent increase
across the board but for young teachers
coming into the profession the first
year is an 8.9 uh pay uh pay settlement
we think that's true inflation there is
that well strike action there is not the
answer to dealing with these
negotiations and
um it the children have already had a
disrupted time during covid and I think
the last thing children need in our
schools is for teachers to take strike
action I would earn to continue talking
continue discussing and of course it's
the independent pay review body that
will determine uh the pay for next year
and and they have for this year it's not
just School also is it I mean we've seen
the rmt again are now saying that
they're going to strike over Christmas
from Christmas Eve to the day after
boxing day um your colleague Mark Harper
hasn't got a grip on this either well
he's urging the parties to get together
he's facilitating those discussions but
look the rmt is a very disappointing
decision they've been offered by the
employers eight percent rise over two
years if you look at the pay settlements
below but if you look at the pay
settlements outside the public sector
they are generally in the four to six
percent pay range we simply cannot
afford to pay the kind of uh pay demands
that the the the units like the rmt are
paying if we gave if the if all the
Union's demands and the public sector
were agreed we'll be paying an extra 28
billion pounds on the payroll is simply
not affordable we have to tackle the
inflationary pressures in our economy
that's what we're seeking to do that's
what the Autumn statement was all about
as well as being as well as introducing
measures to help people with those cost
of living increases we also have to
tackle inflation that's what's causing
households to pay higher bills and these
sorts of paid demands of 19 and so on
are just not affordable in in the public
it's oriented in the private sector we
just may need the unions to work with
our employers and not to hold the
countries around Collective Union action
brings down governments
well we are negotiating with these with
the unions we're talking to the teaching
unions and the leadership unions and the
mark Harper is facilitating those
discussions
well you know I think the public will
not smile upon the rnt if they start
disrupting train travel in the run-up to
Christmas is a very cold time of year as
we know from the from the news about the
today's temperatures but to do so in the
run-up to Christmas I think is
unacceptable and you cannot hold you
cannot have negotiations overpay uh
while holding the country to to Ransom
we do understand the pressures that the
cost of living pressures that people are
facing and that's what we sought to help
deal with in the Autumn statement that
we had a few weeks ago okay talk to me
about the u-turn on housing your 2019
Manifesto pledged to build 300 000 new
homes a year why is the prime minister
now changing his tune and we are
committed to that we want young people
and not so young people to be able to
get on the housing that the conservative
party it's in our DNA for young people
for people to have uh their own home to
the property owning a democracy is part
of what we stand for and we are
committed to that it's not a heating you
need to you need to work with
parliamentarians they represent people
they uh and their communities we want
there to be Community consent to
building more houses that's how you
deliver these targets of hundreds of
thousands of new homes every year to
make sure that when you make decisions
about warehouses are going to be built
uh that's not a Utah no it's it's
working with parliamentarians is this a
U-turn is this a U-turn
um it looks as though the prime minister
is going to say that onshore wind farms
can go ahead this is all part of the
normal process of taking a bill through
Parliament MPS representative
that he was definitely not in favor of
it and now we're changing his mind was
three months the emphasis is on offshore
wind we are one of the world's leading
suppliers of offshore wind something
like 40 of our energy now comes from
clean renewable sources 99 of solar
power told me in August that they would
he would definitely not be in favor of
onshore wind and uh as I said our
emphasis is still on offshore wind but
when you take legislation through
Parliament you have to uh you have to
discussion you look you use the phrase
you turn I use the phrase parliamentary
democracy this is the normal process of
getting the legislation through parties
at the time you listen to members of
parm you talk to members of parliament
as you take measures through why didn't
you say that the emphasis is still on
offshore wind as a source of of our wind
it's creating hundreds of thousands of
jobs it's as I said 40 of our power now
comes from why didn't he say it's a
parliamentary process what he said was
no I am against onshore wind what he's
said in the summer what he's saying now
is that the emphasis must be on offshore
wind and and that is still a position of
the government but of course we'll
continue to talk to members of
parliament as we take this legislation
through Parliament and that is how our
system has always worked and it should
always work well I'll have to let my
viewers decide if it's a U-turn or not
final thought before I let you go
Michelle men's office saying that she's
going to take a legal action about some
of the claims being made about her
company or was it her company certainly
she made it appeared a lot of money out
of Med Pro
29 million pounds apparently out of a
203 million pound contract that's what
the allegation is
um these VIP Lanes
not going to be great either when we
start looking at it well the issue of
banishment that's a is under
investigation so it wouldn't be right
for me to talk about that but what I
would say is if you think back to the
beginning of this covered crisis back in
February March 2020 the government the
country desperately needed PPE in our
hospitals and so that's what these
issues like the VIP Lane was all about
is about making sure that those people
that could change the manufacturing
processes to produce
PPE uh but that was the emphasis of the
government saving lives getting that PP
into Hospital five billion pieces of PPE
were produced as a consequence and that
did save hundreds of thousands of lives
okay we must leave it there we're out of
time but it's great to see you haven't
seen you for ages thank you thanks for
coming in thank you looking at the
morning's papers for you now we should
start with the Daily Mail probably
reporting there's Fury about the claim
in the sussex's Netflix documentary that
there's been a war on Megan
the express leads with that story as
well saying Harry accuses the Palace of
playing a dirty game
while the Sun goes with Sussex lies and
videotape the guardian says the Prime
Minister Rishi sunak is to scrap
compulsory house building targets after
pressure from his back benches
and according to the eye antibiotics to
be given to all children in schools
where there has been a case of strep a
just here and there from the minister
suggesting that that will be on a
case-by-case basis
still to come on the program for you
with a wave of winter strikes
threatening chaos over Christmas
speaking to the National lead officer at
unite representing striking workers
across several sectors
speak to the former British ambassador
to Russia sir Andrew wood as Ukraine
warns of emergency blackouts after more
missile strikes
with temperatures set to plummet in the
coming days ask a meteorologist at the
Met Office just how cold could it get
also making news this morning parents
are resorting to watering down baby
formula according to the charity feed
which says some are also having to give
infants unsuitable food as an
alternative like porridge the British
pregnancy advisory service says the
price of the cheapest formula brands
have jumped 22 percent in the past year
a health security agency has confirmed
an eighth child has died from a strep a
infection government warning parents to
look out for symptoms the infection
usually causes a sore throat a fever or
a skin rash and is passed by a physical
contact or through droplets from
sneezing or coughing
a major incident's been declared in
Wolverhampton after a fire engulfed
several Factory units the West Midlands
fire service said more than 105 Fighters
were on the scene the Blazers caused all
nearby trains to be stopped
the actress Kirsty alley has died at the
age of 71 not long after being diagnosed
with cancer some of her best known work
was in the long-running U.S sitcom
cheers Ali's children paying tribute are
describing her as incredible Fierce and
loving Kamali hasmore
Kirstie Alley was a star of television
and film in the 80s and 90s her children
true and Lily Parker posted a tribute on
Twitter saying their mother had passed
away from recently discovered cancer she
was 71. they said that she died
surrounded by friends and family
Kirstie Alley was best known for her
role as Rebecca Howe on the NBC sitcom
cheers to joined the show at the height
of its popularity in 1987 as the manager
of the iconic bar a role she would win
an Emmy and Golden Globe for in 1991.
Ali also starred alongside Bruce Willis
and John Travolta in the 1989 film look
who's talking and its two sequels John
Travolta posted this on his Instagram
Kirsty was one of the most special
relationships I've ever had I love you
Kirsty I know we will see each other
again
in the last few years of her life Ali
said she felt she'd been blacklisted in
Hollywood due to her support of the
former president Donald Trump her family
say her passion and zest for Life
inspired them to live life to the
fullest just as she did
Kamali Melbourne Sky News
Tim Allen paid tribute to Kirstie Alley
on Twitter saying a Sweet Soul pass on
in Kirsty alley sad sad news prayers for
all her family Maria Shriver also wrote
on Twitter I knew Kirsty for several
decades and interviewed her many times
this is such heartbreaking news that she
had so much more Life to Live she had a
kind heart and a great spirit she loved
her family and she loved life may she
rest in peace and Jamie Lee Curtis
talked to Instagram saying I've just
heard the sad news that Kirsty Alias
died she was a great comic foil in TV
scream queens and a beautiful mama bear
in her real life
and from Taylor Lautner an honor working
with and getting to know you Kirsty rip
quick look at the weather
anticipation is rising and so is the
atmosphere are you ready
the weapon sponsored by Qatar Airways
cold easterly wind will give way to an
even colder Northerly this week bringing
widespread frosts Amid and some snow I
should say to the north uh it's going to
stop mainly dry bright and chilly today
with an extensive Frost in the North and
the West
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
Nash what is your word of the year or
phrase I know it's Sky News breakfast
isn't it but what else Oxford dictionary
has revealed the word of the year and
it's the first time it's been chosen by
the public so what is it
Goblin mode a type of behavior which is
unapologetically self-indulgent lazy
slovenly or greedy typically in a way
that rejects social norms or
expectations there you go that is the
word of the Year well earlier the
school's Minister Nick Gibb tell me the
pay demands of unions whose members are
striking are unaffordable
if all the Union's demands in the public
sector were agreed we'll be paying an
extra 28 billion pounds on the payroll
is simply not affordable we have to
tackle the inflationary pressures in our
economy that's what we're seeking to do
that's what the Autumn statement was all
about as well as being as well as
introducing measures to help people with
those cost of living increases we also
have to tackle inflation that's what's
causing households to pay higher bills
and these sorts of paid demands of 19
and so on are just not affordable in in
the public sector or indeed in the
private sector we just may need the
unions to work with our employers and
not to hold the countries around
okay also asked him about the rmt union
bring that to you very shortly indeed
tomorrow
um is here interesting what are you
saying about
um the unions how much it's going to
cost and also about Utah that's right so
big U-turn from the government last
night although the schools Minister
insisted it wasn't they were just having
a rethink
um basically the government committed in
its Manifesto in 2019 to building 300
000 homes a year but a lot of MPS have
been getting very upset about individual
developments in their constituencies
saying councils then feel they have to
say yes to developments which they don't
think are right and a very large group
of MPS there were 58 of them publicly
named but they say they had a hundred
said we simply don't want these housing
targets anymore and yesterday after a
series of meetings with Michael Gove the
leveling up secretary a compromise was
announced whereby if MPS don't like
housing developments and they think that
they adversely affect the character of
the area so you can see that might be
quite quite broad then they don't have
to have them and that's quite
significant U-turn from Rishi sunak and
we're expecting that there may well be
another one coming quite soon on wind
farms and that's effectively in the
other direction some MPS didn't want
housing developments but some of them
now do want onshore wind which the
government under David Cameron banned a
few years ago and in fact Richie sunac
told us in the summer that he wanted to
keep that ban I think we've got a bit of
Rishi sunak speaking to us in that
debate we do
yes or no no okay you've changed your
mind no I haven't I just last night I
was asked a question I didn't fully
understand it and I misspoke but my
position on that is the same as it's
been
so he told us he didn't want it now a
group of MPS I looked at the amendment
last night being brought by Simon Clark
who's not not one of which you see next
close allies and he has about 35 names
that's not quite enough to defeat the
government yet but I suspect he's got a
few more behind the scenes so will he
have to u-turn on that too there's a
sense of the Prime Minister is being
very easily pulled in different
directions and the speed with which MPS
are gathering 40 or 50 people to force
the government's hand is looking quite
uh it's all happening very quickly and
talking to MPS last night they said if
you get the sense that Tory MPS are not
happy you'd be right
okay and as far as the minister this
morning is concerned he says it's not a
U-turn because it said absolutely in
August absolutely categorically no
onshore wind farms this is what the
minister said today
what he's said in the sum what he's
saying now is that the emphasis must be
on offshore wind and and that is still a
position of the government but of course
we'll continue to talk to members of
parliament as we take this legislation
through Parliament and that is how our
system has always worked and it should
always work
not always that you get a rebellion so
quickly they will find out in the next
couple of days whether that that's going
to change too yeah tomorrow's take at
nine o'clock looking forward to it thank
you
no it's not just the railways going on
strike coffin Builders bin collectors
and Brewers are joining an ever-growing
list of workers taking industrial action
overpay this winter joining us now is
unite's National lead officer that's on
say kazab hello it's good to see you
thanks for joining us on the program
this morning so talk to me um in a bit
more detail if you would please sir
um about the many sectors that you're
representing and what we are expecting
in the coming weeks
good morning and uh a pleasure to be on
we organize across 41 uh different uh
sectors uh there is a strikeway taking
place at the moment uh because uh our
members are having to cope with the cost
of living and have decided to do
something uh about it that includes our
members uh who work as security guards
at Harrods that includes our members at
felixstowe it includes our members at
shelter it includes our members working
for the bus company abelia and of course
we represent people in dnhs
um as well we are more than happy to
negotiate with all of those employers
but unfortunately an awful lot of them
won't and that includes the NHS the
reality and I heard the minister earlier
on uh it takes I think some brass neck
for ministers who have subsidized
lunches to be telling our men members
who are now relying on food banks that
they shouldn't be taking action on pay
and to somehow imply that we are holding
the country to Ransom that is absolutely
not the case our laser focus is on
making sure that we win fair pay for our
members
potentially a coordinated action is that
what the unions are trying to do to
bring this government you would say to
their senses
we would look at where we've got
Employers in the same sector or where
we've got members working for the same
employer and of course we would look to
coordinate action in that way I think
that that just makes absolute sense
that's part of us being absolutely
focused on the workplace and doing
everything that we can to make sure
there are members of the priority and
our members win fair pay
but if the public is um against you does
it bother you if you don't have public
support for your strike action
well at the moment we do have
significant public support and the point
I would make is this our members are the
public the trade unions are still the
largest voluntary organization in this
country our members use those services
and in many cases our members are taking
action actually to say those Services
I'll give the example of the NHS where
we have members being a balloted it's
about pay but it's also about saving the
NHS 133
000 vacancies in the NHS in England
alone that is because of poor pay and
conditions and our members will be
taking action not just for fair and
decent pay but to save that service and
I think the public understand that
are we talking about the private sector
now are we not to believe companies when
they say that they can't afford uh pay
rises in line with inflation
no if you take some examples be very
specific about it we've got members at
Harrods who are taking strike action
they're making profits we've got members
at the abelio bus company they are
making profits the reality is that the
leading companies in the UK over the
past year have increased our profit
margins by two-thirds to higher levels
than what they were at pre-pandemic
levels so we do not accept that
what about
um your members I think baggage handlers
at Heathrow planning to go on strike for
72 hours
um the weekend before Christmas people
miss their flights how much sympathy do
you think they'll have for your cause
then
our preference is not to text track
action our preference is to sit down and
negotiate an agreement so if the
employers are willing to negotiate and
we'll put reasonable offers we will
always sit down and negotiate strike
action is an absolute Last Resort
so what would you say to people who
would perhaps lose their Christmas
holiday because of strike action
we don't want anybody
so those dead Christmas holidays we
don't want anybody to be negatively
impacted that's not the point of this
but we have members who are relying on
food banks I visited a picket line uh a
few days ago where I was speaking to
somebody who slept in his car not
because he wanted to be early on the
picket line but because you've been
evicted because he couldn't afford to
pay his rent that's the situation we
know that's why we're having to take
strike action we hope in a lot of these
cases that it doesn't come to that and
the employers put a fair deal for our
members and we can negotiate settlement
and not have to resort to strike
actually Mr casab good to talk to you
thanks for joining us thank you
looking up some of the other headlines
for you on the program this morning here
we go Elon musk's medical device company
neurolink is under federal investigation
for potentially violating animal testing
law the company is thought to have
killed around 1500 animals following
experiments since 2018 it's currently
developing a brain implant it hopes will
help paralyze people walk again
a state Memorial has taken place in
Beijing in tribute to the former leader
Zhang xiamen who died last Wednesday the
Chinese president was one of many
Chinese officials in attendance and paid
tribute to the late politician for
ensuring the Communist party's survival
from political storms
Ukraine's government is warning of more
emergency blackouts after Russia again
hit power infrastructure with airstrikes
Russia has fired a barrage of missiles
at Targets across Ukraine for the eighth
time in eight weeks just as emergency
blackouts were due to end Ukraine says
four people were killed
and Ukraine is switching to emergency
shot Downs to stabilize its power grid
after those latest Russian missile
attacks joining us now is Andrew Wood
he's a former British ambassador to
Russia and Associate fellow at Chatham
House hello gee thanks for joining us on
the program this morning sir Andrew
what's your take first of all on these
continuing targeted of the energy
supplies that means that they can't have
water they don't get light and heating
is a big challenge
well it's indicative of the fact that
the Russian forces prefer to use
bombardment of various sorts then
actually come faking because they're
um they're present in in a rather
difficult situation they're not doing
very well militarily so they've gone for
this instead
I don't like it I don't think anybody
else do it's like and it's not brave or
likely to have
good results from the Russian point of
view
up to 40 percent
um of the Kiev region we're told
um is without electricity big challenges
for the winter ahead and it looks as
though there is some infighting now
president zielinski turning on um
Klitschko the mayor of uh Kiev saying
he's doing a poor job setting up
Emergency Shelters I'm guessing this is
exactly what the Russians would like to
see happen
yes of course if if the Ukrainian
government and
govern government structure starts to
quarrel too much with it so that's going
to happen
at the same time there are bound to be
some differences that's the only uh
natural
I don't think either of those two men
would wish to get into a position where
the Russians would start to
be dominant over government decisions
um we've heard from the French President
Emmanuel macron common saying that the
West should consider Russia's need for
security guarantees if Moscow agrees to
talks to end the war I mean some might
balk at that but is that the way forward
no it's it's laughable in the present
situation if of course we ever got to
the situation where the Russians were
willing to negotiate a a resolution
which would allow Ukraine to do what it
was which is to be independent to look
after itself and to be free from
Russians feelings that would be a
different matter
but this is actually a present nothing
to forgive the Russians for
what they're doing is pure aggression
unjustified
and a structure of what a master murder
let me quote to you what Mishima krong
actually said I'm sure you know but it's
for the benefits of our viewers who's
talking to the French TV station tf1 he
says we have Europe has to think about
how to give guarantees to Russia the day
it returns to the negotiating table in
other words we the Europeans need to
give Russia something in order for them
to want to come to negotiating
negotiating table in the first place
well I know what you said but the real
meaning of that is that Ukraine should
make concessions which would make the
Russians wish to start negotiating and
press for further concessions
it's also interesting that he uses the
word Europe as so many of them do as
though his opinions were the opinions of
everybody in the EU which they certainly
are not
he's had quite a lot of criticism for
that from
people in the Baltic states for example
and from Finland and so on it's produced
quite a strong reaction against it
talk to me about the German Chancellor
if you would as well as we're on the
matter of European politicians or life
Schultz of course
um saying that Putin's plan to divide
the West has failed
um
is it too early to say that
well yes it's certainly not the Russian
perception
because when people like like Schultz
himself makes certains lots of comments
they would look for a a split within the
EU and within the West as a whole
and certainly what macron was suggesting
is uh conveys to the Russians
that we collectively should be making
decisions now about what sort of
things we should concede to the rations
in order for there to be some sort of a
peace peace achieved
very few people in the east of Ukraine
or for that matter in our country
believe that the Russians are in any
position or any wish to negotiate then
they're not going to negotiate to have
an independent Ukraine able to
decide its own future and able to act on
Democratic principles rather than
supposed authoritarian rule which is
what Putin does
so Andrew just before I let you go I'm
sure you've seen the images of President
Putin driving over the bridge from
Russia to Crimea that was blown up a
month or so ago now how do you think
that will play in Moscow particularly
when I note that he's not actually
driving a Russian car
uh it's a Mercedes
it was designed I imagine to overcome
the fact that he has never been anywhere
near the area of the struggle between
Russia and Ukraine
um but he's been stuck in Moscow
so it's meant to show that they're
making progress and that
he is in charge of that and his
confidence and so on
which is the same sort of appendicular
gesture that zielinski is made by going
to to Hassan for example or any other
parts of Russia of the Ukraine
yeah
um it's good to see you Sandra thank you
for taking the time in for your
expertise as always thank you thank you
ah weather very very bad indeed in
Ukraine at the moment Sub-Zero
temperatures snow on the ground in an
awful lot of places here in the UK of
course we don't get the sort of
temperatures that they do there but cold
temperatures and perhaps even snow are
on their way over the next few days Alex
Berkeley is a senior operational
meteorologist at the Met Office he's
with us now hello to you thanks very
much indeed for joining us on the
program this morning well I need my big
coat
yes temperatures really are going to
plummet as we go through this week
really and it's going to last for quite
a while you've probably already noticed
over the weekend it felt cold that's
because we had an easterly wind and it
was a Brisk one at that
added to the cold steel but as we go
through today and into tomorrow the
winds are going to background and come
from more of a Northerly Direction and
as you'd expect that makes it even
colder still
where will we see snow
so the greatest snow risk will be in
places that are exposed that Northerly
wind so Northern Scotland that's where
we've got a weather warning out for the
whole of Wednesday that's because we
could see five to ten centimeters
building up over above 200 meters or so
so modest Higher Ground but other places
are likely to see a little bit of snow
perhaps as we go through this week
particularly later on in the week as a
few showers start to push their way
southwards it's not a guarantee that
everywhere will see anything by the
nature of showers they're very hit and
miss and so it's very difficult to
forecast exactly where they're going to
fall but the most likely to places to
see the snow will be Northern Scotland
okay so the rest of the country uh rest
of the British Isles so far probably
won't what about as we head through
December
so yeah this week most of the uh most
places will actually stay largely dry
and it's actually going to be quite
bright there'll be a lot of sunshine to
come which is a bit of a different story
to what we've had recently so for many
yes it is actually going to be sunny and
dry this week but bitterly cold and it's
not just by day it's also by night that
we're going to see the temperatures
dropping so tonight I'm expecting lows
around minus five minus six in some
places and as we go through the week by
the weekend there's a potential we could
get into negative double figures which
is going to make it very cold indeed it
does look like this cold weather is
going to continue as we go through the
weekend and into next week There's a bit
of uncertainty thereafter we could see
something milder coming up from the
southwest or we could hold on to this
cold Northerly wind and so it looks like
some cold temperatures are going to stay
with us for a little while yet
here's the big question everybody wants
me to ask is it going to snow for
Christmas
well looking back on records it's around
more just over 50 of our Christmases are
technically white by that I mean at
least one snowflake is reported
somewhere in the UK now that's not the
picturesque views that everyone has of
you know sheets of snow on the ground
and going sledging with their kids but
what we can expect is some further cold
weather to come as we go through
December as I said there are signs that
there could be something a bit milder as
we go through next week and if that wins
out then we'll probably see temperatures
closer to average as we go towards
Christmas day so it's all to play for at
the moment I think there is a chance
that we could see a bit of snow but
there are no strong signs of it being
severe or widespread okay and because
it's so cold now is that anything to do
with global warming or is that just
cyclical
so this is just weather at the moment we
have a Northerly flow coming towards the
UK and so we're going to see
temperatures plummeting because of that
so it's literally just because of where
our air is coming from so we've seen
temperatures like this before it's not
totally out of the ordinary but it's not
an every year occurrence you have to go
back to 2017 2018 for the last time that
we had a cold spell like this at this
time in the year it's usually slightly
later on in the winter around January
February time when we're looking at
negative double figures at night so it
is cold particularly for December
um but it's just because of the where
where our wind is coming from okay it's
great to talk to you Alex thanks very
much indeed for explaining that to us
thank you